[Musica]
andare oltre avere una visione
devo riuscire ad esso a trasmettervi
l'entusiasmo che abbiamo avuto in questo
progetto e collegarlo a questi due
oggetti che ho in mano con questa foto
che ho alle mie spalle molto difficile
un compito molto arduo perché per
parlare di porti telematici ho bisogno
di illustrarvi alcuni concetti molto
particolari che ci permettono poi di
arrivare ad una conclusione è che ci
hanno permesso anche di avere una musica
una visione futura di questo tipo
questa immagine ci fa vedere delle
strade e autostrade del mare di circa 2
300 anni fa sono gli scambi commerciali
prima si chiamava di scambi è bene
parlare di scabbia non di traffici
perché comunque significa che i popoli
avevano qualcosa da scambiarsi le strade
che vengono percorse da queste
imbarcazioni valgono nel momento in cui
sono percorse quando finiscono di
percorrere quella strada quella strada
non c'è più cosa è successo
questa è sempre una mappa di traffici e
quindi di scambi commerciali
evidentemente è successo qualcosa è
cambiato il contesto qualcuno
intervenuto rispetto a prima
dove i traffici avvenivano solo al
centro di questa mappa
come potete vedere come sono stati
aperti dei canali strategici si sono
diffusi notevolmente più passa il tempo
e più le persone hanno bisogno di
scambiarsi qualcosa cose attraverso
delle navi che approdano nei porti
ok
vi faccio vedere un'altra mappa sembra
una mappa antica ma e modernissima
questa mappa del 2015
anche qui ci sono delle strade poche
rispetto a quelle che abbiamo visto
prima sono le autostrade telematiche
ognuno ognuna di quelle strade
rappresenta uno scambio di informazioni
perché i popoli anche hanno qualcosa da
dirsi oltre che qualcosa da scambiarsi
no sennò non ci sarebbe mai stato un
collegamento fra un continente all'altro
quindi popoli hanno bisogno di scambiare
anche informazioni ok
questa è una mappa diciamo più
stilizzata rispetto a quella di prima ma
è la stessa identica cosa
tutti quei punti però non sono dei porti
ognuno di quei punti è una destinazione
di un'autostrada l'autostrada
informatica cioè di un cavo sottomarino
in fibra ottica abbiamo iniziato a
posare cavi non in fibra ottica
un centinaio di anni fa per le
telecomunicazioni per il treno europa e
stati uniti
questa attualmente questa mappa
attualmente rappresenta i punti cioè le
cable landing station dove atterrano
questi cavi sottomarini che sono
attualmente 423 quindi evidentemente
negli ultimi 20 anni sono stati posati
la maggior parte di questi cavi in
ognuno di questi cavi passano delle
informazioni che vengono prodotte
quotidianamente dagli esseri umani
questa è per esempio la situazione nella
zona più vicino a noi
l'italia vi ricordo che ognuno di quei
punti non rappresenta necessariamente un
porto ma una cable landing station cioè
un luogo dove atterrano questi cavi
sottomarini che si incontrano tra di
loro per interconnettersi
all'interno di questi cavi passa all 80
per cento di tutto il traffico delle
informazioni della rete internet in
quale epoca in questo momento ci
troviamo
l'abbiamo riassunto qui in pochi punti
tra il 1970 e il 2000 eravamo nell'epoca
della data age denominata la gigabyte
age l'epoca in cui non c'era ancora
internet come lo conosciamo oggi ma
comunque i dati venivano generati poi si
è passati in un periodo molto più breve
dal 2000 2010 all'era del terabyte age
per esempio questo oggetto è un disco da
un terabyte
oggi viviamo l'era dei petabyte age dal
2010 al 2020 siamo proprio in questo
momento l'epoca in cui i social network
gli smartphone hanno dato la possibilità
a tutti noi di generare dei contenuti
come non è mai successo in passato che
cosa succederà nei prossimi dieci anni
entreremo in un'era in una data age
molto particolare anche difficile
descriverla numericamente ed è per
quello che è stato dato un nome a a
queste queste grandezze ed entreremo
nell'era dell'exa by the age l'era
dell'intelligenza artificiale delle
analytics l'era in cui i dati
produrranno dei dati e già sta avvenendo
in questo momento il 90 per cento di
tutti i dati mondiali sono stati
generati negli ultimi due anni
ogni giorno questo numero molto
difficile da leggere però è la quantità
di byte generati quotidianamente sono 25
miliardi di miliardi di byte 25 milioni
di terabyte 25 milioni di questi hard
disk ogni giorno oggi ma dove ci
troviamo nella goldstick cioè nel
grafico nella scala di crescita lì è
indicato
se noi prendiamo quel piccolo pezzo cioè
gli anni in cui noi stiamo vivendo loro
ingrandiamo vediamo sì una crescita
abbastanza sostenuta ma guardiate dove
ci troviamo
è impressionante
questo si chiama industria digitale
siamo in pieno periodo dell'industria
digitale
ora come facciamo ad entrare nel
discorso del porto telematico
da qui nasce la visione l'italia è un
paese che c'è per alcune cose esiste per
altre cose non esiste però ci siamo
l'italia in questo momento c'è ed esiste
per alcuni settori industriali fashion
food ma non esiste per altri settori
assolutamente non esiste nel settore
della digital incastri perché non
esistiamo esistiamo in altri settori
perché sicuramente noi viviamo di
rendita del passato della storia quello
che ci hanno regalato chi è venuto prima
di noi però da alcuni anni si è smesso
di pensare si è smesso di innovare si è
smesso di abbiamo spesso di avere una
visione forse appagati di tutto il
patrimonio culturale che è stato
accumulato negli anni precedenti
beh fino a un certo punto ci è andata
bene però i dati dimostrano che sia
adesso non riprendiamo ad innovare non
riprendiamo a pensare ea crederci ed
avere una visione
sicuramente non riusciremo a creare un
futuro per le generazioni che verranno
per i nostri figli quindi pensando i
nostri figli è nato questo progetto il
progetto dei porti telematici
quello che in questo momento noi
dobbiamo immaginare è che se noi
prendiamo l'italia e vediamo che la
maggior parte del nostro territorio è
formato da coste e pensiamo anche a
quanti porti effettivamente abbiamo e
quanta informazione abbiamo da scambiare
in quale contesto geografico ci troviamo
noi ci troviamo alla metà del globo
perché ovviamente siamo abituati a
guardare la mappa o in un altro mondo da
quel punto di vista senz'altro siamo a
metà strada tra l'asia e gli stati uniti
le interconnessioni cavi che dovranno
essere realizzati e i data center suoi
luoghi dove verranno costruiti i nostri
dati da qui in avanti guardando il
grafico che ho fatto vedere prima
saranno devastanti lo sviluppo sarà
impressionante per farci notare qui è
molto semplice se uno di voi in questo
momento dovesse alzare la mano verrebbe
subito notato offerte esiste esistere
vuol dire anche essere importante e
rilevante
l'italia in questo settore non è
importante e non è neanche rilevate
perché nessuno alzato la mano e se noi
prendiamo questo contesto lo riportiamo
all'interno di uno stadio dove ci sono
30 mila persone
beh non vale più il discorso appena
fatto nel senso che se uno alza la mano
all'interno di uno stadio è difficile
che venga notato come all'interno di
questa stanza allora deve alzare 2 di
mani ma non basta la deve avere una
bandiera deve urlare
noi dobbiamo alzare la mano quello che
abbiamo fatto è semplicemente alzare la
mano è semplicemente alzare la mano vuol
dire esistiamo
siamo importanti e siamo rilevanti
laddove esiste un porto commerciale è
possibile perché è possibile abbinare
una cable landing station
c'è un approdo per i cavi sottomarini è
un data center dove all'interno noi
custodiremo i dati che sono la cosa più
preziosa che abbiamo perché abbiamo
qualcosa
da dire e abbiamo qualcosa da scambiarci
da qui in avanti sarà sempre di più ed è
anche difficile immaginare da qui in
avanti la quantità di dati che verrà
prodotta se noi non entriamo in
quest'ottica se noi non sfruttiamo
questa grandissima opportunità questa
straordinaria opportunità
queste cose verranno fatte in altri
paesi d'europa
se son riuscito un minimo a trasmettervi
l'entusiasmo l'idea l'opportunità di
creare di convertire o di riqualificare
o di affiancare ai porti commerciali
il porto telematico è evidente che noi
risolveremo determinate situazioni
determinate determinate situazioni che
in questo momento sono critiche per il
nostro paese
se diversamente non ci sono riuscito noi
ci sforzeremo io mi sforzerò per
continuare a diffondere questa visione
perché crediamo molto in questa
opportunità dell'industria digitale
grazie
[Applauso]